aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
changements climatiques il est tel que
s'il faut faire quelque chose vraiment
aujourd'hui parce que moi je suis dans
une eau à côté d'orléans c'est le joueur
une grande forêt domaniale de france et
donc tout doit être fait en même temps
c'est à dire qu'à la fois on salue les
pompiers mais aussi il faudra regarder
en sorte que les pompiers volontaires
soient aidés alors que jusqu'à présent
d'un territoire à l'autre on n'était pas
les entreprises à libérer des des
pompiers et de l'autre côté dans nos
forêts c'est une accélération b est
énorme ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que quand nos chaînes moi ya des chaînes
chez moi non ne trouve plus d'eau et
bien finalement c'est leurs défenses
immunitaires comme nous qui regrette un
coût et donc beaucoup de maladies voilà
donc parce que les défenses immunitaires
je suis affaibli moi je suis l'arbre je
suis affaibli parce que j'ai plus d'eau
et donc là on va avoir des parasites qui
veut revenir m'attaquez et donc on voit
bien qu'il faudra faire quelque chose
immédiatement
alors il y à lodève qui s'en occupe il
ya aussi de la faute et forêts privées
qui qui s'y met beaucoup les deux tiers
des forêts en france le pré sont privés
de toute façon on pourra pas faire des
monocultures on sait aujourd'hui que si
on veut faire en sorte que nos forêts
restent nos forêts il faudra à la fois
jouer sur la densité au à l'hectare et
aussi sur les espèces et sur dd des
variétés et je le dis aussi parce que on
a aussi un problème lié à l'engagement
de nos forêts moi je porterai un texte
contre le grillage mans parce que
imaginer demain qu'avec des d hectares
qui soit engagé les animaux sauvages
donc l'engagement c'est mettre un
grillage autour et on verra par exemple
indexée par exemple vous avez des plans
de chasse où tout est en grillage et
imaginent demain en sologne on est des
feux ça veut dire que tous ces animaux
sauvages ont cramé sur place et donc là
aussi c'est à dire qu'il faut regarder
évidemment le problème d essence mais
regardez également toutes les
conséquences qui sont autour la forêt a
toujours été un enjeu au parlement
contrairement à ce qu'on croit il ya eu
des débats et des débats portant sur sur
la forêt ça a été toujours compliqué
mois que la page était lui en 2017 j'ai
été voir le aux nefs je voulais faire
des jeux pour enfants tu connais ta
forêt le nef trois fois j'aurais écrit
pas de réponse parce qu'ils te dire que
le personnage on l'a compris tous les
valeurs visiter leur une espèce de vaz
clos auquel on avait l'impression qu'on
n'avait pas en droit de les déranger et
est donc ça c'était un problème et donc
moi je je je pense que c'est il faut
s'appuyer sur le nf il ya eu des
problèmes de gouvernance il y avait
vraiment des gens qui étaient vraiment
des passionnés qui mettait plus d'heures
que ce qu'il fallait mais aussi il
devait aussi se rendre compte et puis on
a une chance marc fesneau le ministre
actuel de l'agriculture est un passionné
de forêt il était maire de marchenoir
d'un petit village il a été 2 le premier
à monter public une cuma pour faire du
bois énergie et donc public est donc un
marché noir il a il a mis en place cette
affaire là et donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas opposer la
gestion privée à la gestion publique il
faut regarder ce qui se fait alors moi
j'ai rien contre les groupes qui
viennent évidemment dans nos forêts
faire du bois mais ce qui a beaucoup
choqué c'est quand on les voit arriver
maintenant avec du matériel à chenilles
qui détruit tout c'est à dire que à la
voix il n'y a pas de problème il faut
qu'ils viennent entretenir nos forêts
mais de l'autre côté attention y'a pas
que l'arbre lui même il ya aussi une
biodiversité qui doit pas être détruite
parce que pour faire plus de fric on on
a du matériel qui abîme tout autour et
donc c'est tout ça sur lequel il va
falloir aller vite et essayer de voir et
puis également pardon nos scieries c'est
à dire qu'un des problèmes que l'on a
c'est qu'il faut remonter une filière
complète ça veut dire que aujourd'hui
quand on a une scierie c'est beaucoup de
stock d'argent c'est à dire que
contrairement à d'autres choses
auxquelles vous jouez en bourse l'aller
le trader en 10 secondes ils ont gagné
de l'argent la dans un morceau d'arbres
vous allez peut-être le garder 4 5 ans
donc c'est des cdc des stocks énormes et
là il faudra faire quelque chose par
dont il faudra avoir une fille une
fiscalité particulière sur la forêt
c'est à dire qu' il faut faire en sorte
que les investissements à long terme sur
la forêt se permettent à ceux qui en
font partie
parce que c'est compliqué financièrement
de pouvoir avoir des facilités notamment
à ne pas rentrer le stock dans dans je
dirais le bénéfice et et pouvoir les
études sur le terrain partout en france
depuis une dizaine d'années il ya eu des
crues qu'on n'avait jamais vu moi dans
mon village a failli aux loges dans le
loiret il y avait deux mètres d'eau et
donc on va reconnaît les événements
extrêmes soit on le supplie la
difficulté la difficulté c'est la
coordination entre l'europe la france et
le terrain et dont l'europe est née à
l'avant garde donc pas pour le sport est
à l'avant-garde elle dit notre feuille
de route c'est moins 55 pourri mais co2
d'ici 2040 vous regardez la loi climat
france ô c'est moins car on est le
producteur ce qui est important c'est
d'appliquer mais là où vous avez raison
c'est que de toute façon on pourra pas
faire ce qui a été fait là où le
politique a eu par exemple à un moment
donné ils voulaient des constructions
pour faire de l'argent parce que comme
ça il faisait sa salle de sport etc et
on construisait à des endroits tentant
savait qu'il ne fallait pas construire
là il ya une responsabilité politique
mais je pense que ce temps-là est
terminée que l'ensemble des politiques
je parle bien des mères moi c'était vers
et fanta sonde les fantassins de la
politique les quel que soit le bord ils
font très attention mais attention on
peut pas ne pas vouloir ne pas avoir d'
extension de maison et ne pas densifier
les bourgs c'est à dire que les
écologistes faut qu'ils se mettent
d'accord on peut pas ne pas construire
dans le bourg en densifiant et pourquoi
aimez autres sur le coup